economía en france 24 estamos para esa
materia con danger hablando no esa
periodista experta ni la bienvenida
nuevamente empezamos hablando los
gigantes de wall street y de la
industria que rechazar una posible alza
en los impuestos o la ley liana esta es
una queja de 250 grandes empresas entre
ellas jaypee morgan blackrock pzifer y
news corp entre muchas otras también de
la gran banca de manhattan sus
ejecutivos crearon un grupo de presión
llamado partnership for new york city
para rechazar una potencial subida de
impuestos en el estado de nueva york que
está contemplada en un proyecto de
presupuesto local la misma bolsa de
nueva york ya ha dicho que podría dejar
manhattan si esto llegara a suceder y
una de las promesas de campaña de joe
biden fue elevar el impuesto corporativo
del 21 al 28 por ciento hoy en una
audiencia ante el congreso de hecho la
secretaria del tesoro recordó que la
propuesta sigue entre los planes liliana
bueno a daniela y renunció el presidente
del banco de desarrollo de américa
latina que antes era la corporación
la corporación andina de fomento que es
un organismo para la región que el año
pasado prestó más de 14 mil millones de
dólares a los diferentes países su
presidente desde 2017
el peruano luis carranza presentó su
renuncia efectiva a partir de abril un
año antes de lo previsto y sacudió de
paso los cimientos de esta entidad con
sede en caracas sobre su salida biljana
hay muchas versiones que van desde
supuesta corrupción hasta un posible
abuso de poder una de esas denuncias
viene de alejandra claros quien se
desempeñó como coordinadora en la
secretaría de la entidad una vez se
conoció la renuncia de carranza publicó
un tuit en el que advirtió citando la
cuenta de la caf que nadie tiene derecho
a lastimar a causar u hostigar a otros
pero la versión oficial del directivo en
su carta de renuncia es que recibió
presiones por parte del directorio de
argentina en concreto acusa a este país
de politizar la entidad porque no lo
apoyó en el nombramiento de un alto
cargo ejecutivo y si quiso imponerle a
otra persona
la idea la vamos ahora de reino unido
porque el país impondrá sanciones a
quienes salgan de vacaciones a otras
partes del planeta fuera del país si le
lean a los residentes que se vayan de
vacaciones al extranjero se enfrentarían
a multas de 5 mil libras esterlinas esos
son más o menos cinco mil 789 euros
según la nueva legislación que prepara
el gobierno británico y que será votada
este jueves en el parlamento la nueva
ley impondría multas cuantiosas para
quienes no tengan una razón de fuerza
mayor para salir del país algo que de
hecho no está permitido desde enero y de
ser aprobada el jueves entrarían en
vigor el próximo lunes e irían hasta el
30 de junio las personas que viajen
desde inglaterra a otra parte del reino
unido con el objetivo de abandonar el
país o se dirijan a un aeropuerto con
ese objetivo también van a ser multadas
liliana y la razón de fondo es que no
quieren recibir más casos europeos de
kobe 19 daniela y hablando del mundo de
la música este sector creció en 2020 y
latinoamérica avanzó en la materia cosa
que parecía ser al contrario debido al
coi 19 pues y una buena noticia en medio
de todo
a la pandemia del cob y 19 a cabo como
sabemos con los espectáculos en directo
sin embargo el sector musical generó
ganancias globales de 21.600 millones de
dólares gracias a las reproducciones en
streaming esto muestra un crecimiento
del 7,4 por ciento y marca el sexto año
consecutivo de saldo positivo esto según
los datos divulgados por la federación
internacional de la industria
fonográfica latinoamérica como lo decía
reforzó su posición como el mercado de
mayor crecimiento liliana un 15,9 por
ciento seguido de áfrica en europa el
alza fue del 35 por ciento y me cuento
que las plataformas musicales de pago se
llevaron gran parte de los ingresos de
la industria a finales de 2020 ya tenían
443 millones de usuarios bueno y vamos
con los indicadores de la jornada àngel
a la comparecencia de janet yellen y del
presidente de la fed en el congreso
impulsaron un cierre negativo en wall
street en europa la bolsa de alemania
cerró plana a pesar de la prolongación
de las medidas de confinamiento y
latinoamérica un día rojo para las
principales bolsas que bajaron más
1 % y finalizamos con la cita del día en
99 % se desplomó el producto interno
bruto de argentina el año pasado uno de
sus peores desempeños históricos y
también una de las caídas más drásticas
de toda la región es por la información
de economía y hosterías por estar aquí
en france 24 ustedes continúen con más
centrado 24 punto como nos vemos más
adelante
[Música]
y